للوصفات السياسيه ولا الاتفاقيه الانسانيه
نجحت حتى اللحظه في ارساء تهدئه في
السودان
ومع اصوات القتال تخفت الدبلوماسيه او
هكذا يفهم من المشهد الميداني الذي يزداد
تعقيدا في خطوه متوقعه اعد قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان خلط بعض اوراق مجلس
السياده الانتقالي المختلف عليه اصلا
واجرى سلسله تعينات جديده في هرم القياده
العسكريه في مرسوم دستوري اصدره البرهان
اقال نائبه وخصمه قائد الدعم السريع من
منصبه نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده وعين رئيس
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان مالك عقار
بدلا منه نائبا لرئيس المجلس وعين الفريق
اول ركن شمس الدين كباشي نائبا للقائد
العام للقوات المسلحه والفريق اول ركن
ياسر العطا مساعدا للقائد العام للقوات
المسلحه والفريق بحري مهندس ابراهيم جابر
مساعدا للقائد العام
المسلحه ميدانيا افاد مراسل الجزيره ان
طائرات الجيش قصفت مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع في حي شامبات ومناطق شمال الخرطوم
مع تحليق مكثف للمقاتلات في سماء العاصمه
لاسيما ام درمان والخرطوم بحري ويقول
الجيش ان قوته مستمره في تنشيط الاحياء في
منطقه ابو حمامه بالعاصمه ورصد مراسل
الجزيره دخول اليات عسكريه للجيش السوداني
الى الخرطوم وقال مصدر عسكري بالجيش ان
الاليات استقدمت من قياده المدفعيه بمدينه
عطبره شمالي البلاد وفي نيال جنوب دارفور
تجددت الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
مع ورود انباء عن سقوط اصابات واتهمت قوات
الدعم السريع الجيش بقصف عدد من الاحياء
السكنيه بالمدافع الثقيله في المدينه
وسط ذلك تتفاقم الازمه الانسانيه المتحدث
باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين قال ان اكثر من مليون شخص
نزحوا ولجاوا حتى الان بسبب القتال